all together with the heads of the
regions of the federation
representatives of the government of the
federal agencies
we are in vladivostok today and today
we have started the
eastern economic forum which has the
heads of the leading companies uh the
entrepreneurs that are already involved
or planned to start a business in the
far east
and
we have also representatives of the
business circles and we are going to
keep in mind there are suggestions when
we will plan for our next steps to
develop the far east last year the
new presidential decree was
issued on the measures of the
socio-economic development and the
national program of the development of
the region was launched
that was
designed for up to 2035
first of all we expect
it wants to attract people
to make it more populated to improve the
living standards
i would like to ask all the heads of the
municipalities of the region to
implement all the items on this program
and we need to think about financial and
organizational resources and here is
something that i would like to draw your
attention to
the history of the development of the
forest implementation of large
significant projects like the
trans-siberian
brood construction the spaceport festucy
construction other large
facilities and sites for the
asian summit it showed how important it
is to keep moving forward and we have
just seen
how
other projects are being implemented how
our plans are being implemented
and we need to set ambitious goals we
need to try to
reach the most ambitious
targets
and we shouldn't think about the current
situation we should think strategically
we should think about the future and
just a number of examples that i would
like to give you
so
because it we took too much to expand
the throughput capacity of our
railroads of course there were a lot of
uh
thoughts and it seemed to be objective
the reasons we didn't do this it was
based on the calculations of the market
but unfortunately
all these calculations or
miscalculations
well sadly or maybe fortunately
for our coal miners so
they weren't justified
and the situation we have on our hands
is different
but we haven't prepared the
infrastructure
and
we can't
fully use the beneficial situation at
the global coal market we can't increase
the export the way we could have
of course it's uh missed
value
for the region for the entire
state because we could have allocated
these funds to
develop the infrastructure all over the
country i remember how it went so it was
a risky venture but then the life turned
out different and so it's a loss of
profit that we could have had that we
could have gained
so that's why we need to work on social
infrastructure for the people who live
here or who plan to come they don't only
need jobs they need high living
standards
and not somewhere in the future in the
distant future but already now already
today or in the nearest future
we need towns and the cities we need
quality educations we need transport we
need communications we need
contemporary communications modern
communications advanced communications
if we only use some
papers and not the federal program for
the development of the far east
then we wouldn't be able to develop
in the
pace that we want to we wouldn't be able
to develop as rapidly as we would like
to so we need to invest now to get
results in the future so first we will
hear out the reports i would like to
talk in detail about two things
the flights we have subsidized tickets
program
for the flight from the forest to the
european part of russia this year it
covers not only the
younger people retirees many children
families but all the people in the far
east but
in some of the regions people weren't
able to buy the subsidized tickets or
they ran out of these tickets even
though it's still not the end of the
year or maybe the region didn't get this
subsidies
we have just talked to the minister of
transport about this and i would like
you to hear me first of all i'm talking
to the federal ministries colleagues of
course this situation is unacceptable
the matter of the preferential rates
must be controlled at all times
and i'm not talking about
lack of something at some time
i talked to the minister every year
there is a
big problem to get the subsidies in the
government but listen all the people in
the russian federation
all of us we live in one country
and
we need to make all our regions
connected
and uh
we need to allow people to move around
the country freely so all these
subsidies must be issued automatically i
would like to ask ministry of finance of
transfer other agencies to think about
it and to think about how we can
do this so it's not that difficult we
need to think about the system that
would allocate necessary funds
automatically
i'm talking about the things that i've
just mentioned
i'm talking about a very important very
sensitive issue
preferential rates must be accessible
for all the people in the forest
throughout the entire year
and to do that of course we need to
increase the amount of the flights
especially at the peak periods and then
we need to increase the connectivity
between the regions inside the forest
and we need to expand the network of the
intra-regional routes we need to update
the car fleet of the
corresponding companies and we have
talked about this a lot
and
people are working but we need to pick
up the tempo and we need to think about
people when we do this
we have already created unified far
eastern air company based on aurora air
companies so it started working in july
and before the end of the year this
company
will
make flights on 20 new routes and before
2025 the total amount of the flights
that are going to be served by aurora
will be should be more 530.
i would like to draw your attention to
the fact that the flights
should be made in the direction that
people need and the price should be
affordable
only in this case
the passenger amount of passengers will
increase
and the people should be able to afford
to buy the tickets and the company plans
to increase its fleet of planes to buy
45 new russian produced planes
and they are going to report on how this
work will be done and uh the next thing
that i would like to draw your attention
to a lot of uh
settlements in the far east are located
remotely and for their citizens flight
is probably the only way to get to the
mainland and smaller airports even if
they only have a few flights per week
they must respond to the same demands at
the large uh aviation hub or at least
almost the same i'm talking about the
safety and the protection of the
infrastructure
and the special
crews
to react in case of emergencies so we'd
like to instruct the government
to read this smaller airport from
excessive demands of course
not to give anyone stupid ideas we
shouldn't damage safety but if you look
closely if you read closely i mean all
these instructions and all these
requirements probably you will find
there is something that is excessive for
smaller airports and serve as a burden
to them and we need to continue to
develop the network of the smaller
air
airports
and the small aviation sanitary aviation
helped a lot during the pandemic when
the sikh patients were admitted to the
leading hospitals of the region's creek
and the doctors of the far east like
their counterparts all over russia work
hard
and i would like to
thank them for this
and it's obvious that there are still
problems persist
in the far eastern healthcare because
there is not enough specialists
and
primarily in primary care needs to be
updated
and this year we have started the
upgrade program for all the primary link
in the healthcare so i would like to
hear how this program is being
implemented in the forest i know i would
like to go back to what i talked about
in the beginning we should remember the
specific features of the forest we
shouldn't use some average formulas
average calculations or patterns here
because it would be wrong
it is unacceptable because
in this case we wouldn't be able to see
any significant changes if we will use
these patterns we won't get any good
results because in the forest there are
a lot of small towns and the distance
between these towns can be hundreds of
kilometers and the
funding model for the healthcare is not
working as good as in the other region
people can't access the quality
healthcare
so and the equipment that they have for
the hospitals leaves
much to be desired
and people who face certain problems
sickness illnesses they don't think
about any paperwork they don't think
about norms
even though they might be written good
they need an outpatient cleaning they
need a hospital they need a healthcare
center
maybe
something small but some place where
they can get help or they can talk to
doctors where they have good equipment
so we need to come up with a special
approach that would keep in mind the
specific features of the small
settlements so i would like to hear
about the suggestions from the
government we talked certain about
certain things yesterday and earlier
today so obviously it will need
some time to think about it but the
matter of social guarantees of the
social development and the foreign so
these matters must not be approached
formally
there are some suggestions so we need to
think about them
and we talked about this yesterday with
our colleagues and i instructed them to
think more about it to pay special
attention to it hopefully it will be
done in the near future i'm not only
talking about healthcare but also about
education and some other areas and we
start the program of the medical
rehabilitation of the people including
those who recovered from the coronavirus
to give them the chance to recover their
health completely so so far here in the
far east we don't have enough capacities
to rehabilitate all the people in the
region
at least those who really need this but
the support and the help
that's what people need already now so i
would like to
[Music]
think about possible solutions under
this program for the far eastern
population and so let's uh talk about
all the issues that i mentioned now if
you think that i forgot about something
then please raise all the necessary
issues
so please i give the floor to my
colleagues thank you
today we have already built
2604 projects
and uh
we have increased the number we are
going to have the new building called
the airport and khabarovsk the factory
of the amino acids
and
we're going to have the greenhouse
complex that will provide the
region with vegetables and fruit
and we have finally managed to put
forward
the enterprises like
odycon and trans biker
and other projects that were able to be
that we were able to implement finally
after decades of doing nothing because
of the state support and the volume of
the investment that we get at the far
east is 2 trillion rubles and i'm only
talking about the state support here
more than 81 000 jobs were created
the
conditions to develop the far east are
are achieved with the projects that were
created from the direct instructions of
mr president
the power of siberia guys pipeline and
the guys recycling because refining
factory and the construction of the far
eastern state university where we are
sitting now and the economy of the far
east is
growing quickly and the
gdp
of the far east
is growing faster than russia in russian
average and the industrial production is
also higher
than on average in russian the
investment
per capita
uh or 39 higher than on average in
russia the volume of the
direct investment is 80 billion dollars
currently
the mechanisms
that
we are using allowed us to
develop even further the
fishing industry and we are building uh
new fishing
ships now in the
ship building facilities of bloody
vostok
and the income from this fishing
industry
has become
much much bigger than in the previous
years i would like to mention that the
state investments in the economy of the
far east i'm talking about the tax
refunds
and the infrastructure investments have
been returned and the taxes from the
enterprises that have been built as more
than 123 billion rubles with the
expenses of the state to support them
of 81 billion rubles so the funds that
were invested from the budget of the
russian federation to develop the
economy of the forest were renumerated
already back in 2018 three years after
the preferential regimes were launched
and they have already brought 42 billion
rubles to the
state budget
at the same time i should mention that
the economy of the far east was damaged
by the pandemic in a bigger way than
other economies the reason is that the
most part of the products
created
in the far east is aimed at the pacific
region markets and the restrictions
caused by the pandemic damage to land
the farming in the far east for example
and to compensate it to
reroute it to other markets to the
domestic market it took more time than
we expected and
the number of investment decreased after
the 2020 but
this year we have started to go back to
the pre-crisis
indicators and figures
and um
all enterprises invested with the state
support investment
more than 500 tribbles in their projects
which is more than in 2019 to overcome
the economic crisis caused by the
pandemic and looking for the vase for
the waste to develop the region is one
of the most important topics that
we are talking about at the
far eastern economic forum now about
social development it is obviously that
these 2600 enterprises that are being
built are creating jobs and and
improving the infrastructure in the far
east new enterprises are hiring new
employees
and in the forest we have 10.7
demand for the new employees
and uh
the ministry
of the far eastern development program
has influenced and helped us a lot
it was supposed to provide the living
condition for the people who work at the
new enterprises but during the
implementation of this program we saw
that the implementation of the goals
that you said to improve the quality of
life for the people in the forest would
be impossible
without expanding this program to the
entire territory of the far east so
that's what we did
we are talking about hospitals schools
kindergartens cultural sites sport
facilities in the forest more than 94
000 far eastern people they got lots of
lens
under the program of the far eastern
hectare and a lot of people used
subsidized mortgage but at the same time
we understand that that's not enough and
among the most urgent issues that we are
talking about at the high price for the
food basket that we have
and this price is higher than in the
rest of russia if we talk about the
consumer basket numbers
and other important problem is the
quality of health care education the
state of droughts and infrastructure in
the cities and towns and a lot of these
issues will be resolved under the
program of the national goals
that must be reached in the far east and
and in every region of the russian
federation as well i would like to talk
in more detail about other urgent issues
for the far east and to make a number of
suggestions so first the main reason
to the the main way to
to improve the quality of life
is to
spend more money
because the some regions are on average
have lower living conditions than
on average in russia
so mr putin i would like to you to
instruct the ministry of finance
to provide gradual
bringing out the regions the far eastern
agents to help them to attain the
average russian federation level and
another important goal that we have is
improving the demographics
and we have been implementing the
the program of the subsidies for every
third children
and the
birth rate
that we have here is one of the highest
across the country is two so we suggest
expanding the sahalin experience
and the mechanisms
for the entire region to increase the
amount for the new children
and because
this
impetus will help families to make
decisions about having the first and the
second
children because we
saw it from the experience that the
other regions have so it allowed to
increase the to improve the demographics
and the state of the far eastern cities
is also an important factors that
influence the desire of the people to
come to the region to work in the region
so i suggest to think about making a
decision about the full-scale renovation
of the cities in the forest so thank you
for your permanent support
so please the next report
mr putin i think i can talk for every
person from the magadan region so i
would like to thank you for the
initiatives that you came up with in the
social sphere that allow us to
change life to the better to increase
the salaries for the teachers free meals
for the school children
renovation of the schools and of the
sport facilities construction of new
facilities so that's what we have
finally achieved we for example
yesterday we opened a new school the
first one in the last 35 years we have a
lot of good changes and healthcare for
example we are buying new equipment
mobile equipment we are increasing
salaries of the medical professionals we
are upgrading the primary care
system but at the same time we still
face certain issues and certain problems
and that's
what i would like to talk about within
my report
two years during the eastern economic
forum we talked about healthcare
problems and after this time as per your
instructions we have made significant
progress to upgrade the infrastructure
in our healthcare system
we increased this
the far east increased its share in the
total amount of funding allocated to the
health care all over russia
and before 2024
we plan to upgrade
563 health care sides which is 50 from
the total demand but at the same time
health care indicators for the people in
the forest are
lower than on average in russia
people are unsatisfied with the quality
of health care it's one of the key
reasons why people leave the far east
and you set some serious goals to
increase the
life expectancy for five years and to
decrease the death rate of the
people by no less than 35 percent and
implementing these goals we would like
to see additional measures to improve
the health care in the forest
and the practice shows that the funding
of the obligatory insurance
it doesn't work if we talk about
settlements where less than 10 000
people leave and
there are 94 of such settlements in the
far as 20 percent of the entire
population of the forest leave in such
settlements remoteness lack of the
transport accessibility are some of the
urgent issues that we face so that's why
they can get health care in time they
can get medical help in time
and they don't even have the roads that
they can access at all times only 42
percent correspond to the standards
so to improve the accessibility of the
medical help regions have to
have to have
health care that do not correspond to
the
requirements and standards
and they don't get enough funding
from the obligatory insurance
and from the audience that
the
quality control healthcare quality
control
made we found that
23 of the hospital beds and 54
of the outpatient clinics
they are not up to the norms of the
health care because the population of
their settlements is too small
so that's what's special about health
care in the forest that's what we pay
with to make the health care accessible
and it doesn't have a compulsory
insurance method so i can give you two
examples
magadan region
where
smaller ethnic groups are living
they can only use
aviation to reach hospitals and about
150 days planes can even fly and they
should have an outpatient clinic with 20
medical professionals working there but
actually we have a regional hospital
there where 80 doctors are working
so we have to pay much more to guarantee
the medical help to the people who live
there
paul let's talk about kamchatka
about commodore islands
700 people of population the distance to
petropavlov's kamchatsky
700 kilometers by plane
the transport accessibility is by sea
and only one time per month there's the
ship
going there and for this amount of
people we should have an outpatient
cleaning with the funding from the
compulsory insurance program of three
million rubles but actually the region
has to
fund the regional hospital with
everything
with a surgeon with
any colleges with uh
then
patient
pets and they we have to pay 39 million
reboots so that's why we have deficit
which is covered by
reallocating money
among the healthcare organizations
that work with the compulsory insurance
system these are just two examples but
this situation is similar all across
the far eastern federal
circle
federal region so the entire system
is tuned to achieve the goals of the
national projects
so in magadan
region
program and plans to hire more medical
professional contributes to what we have
in the national program because the
target is 77 doctors per 10 000 people
of the population which is 940 medical
professionals but we only have 750
the similar situation
is for the
medium level medical professionals so we
would like to invite 190 doctors and 189
nurses because we need to
reach the necessary salaries that were
described by the may decrease we need
additional funding of
838 million rubles but the compulsory
insurance program does not pay the
salaries for the people who already work
and the
we already have a deficit of medical
professionals and to
adhere to these normatives we have to
fire more than 600 people obviously we
do not do this we do not do this and the
next problem is paying for the upgrading
infrastructure because we are going
through the
full scale upgrade
of the primary care infrastructure we've
been expecting it but the growth of
expenses to support new outpatient
cleanings new hospitals to buy new
equipment it is not funded completely
and fully
expensive modern equipment quite often
is not used because
there is no budget for buying spare
parts or for the maintenance expenses
so what do regions do under these
conditions first of all they try to
restore the deficit using the funds from
the original budgets and when they can't
do this so they start managing things
manually so to say so either
they tried to unfreeze the arrested
accounts or they agree on delays on
paying the community bills or they use
other measures to
keep hospitals from closing from
shutting down
and
the funding that we get is 22
lower than we actually need and some of
our neighbors this indicator is even
lower and
in 2020 here alone the magadan region
budget
paid 800 million rubles to
pay
for the lack of funding that we got from
the compulsory insurance system and
we have already spent about 600 million
for the same thing and we have to do
this by decreasing
funding for other important social
things and the total deficit of the
health care budget
it has been audited by the ministry of
finance by the ministry of the finance
and have been reaffirmed by the meeting
cheered by the
in september of 2020
and the regional health care system in
the far east
so has been proven by the
by the federal agencies because
we don't have
all necessary tools to regulate these
things
and
the norms that we have they do not
reflect the regional peculiarities for
example per capita norms they
don't use the price for the actual
health care medical help that's why
they can't pay for the
help to people who live and remote
settlements
because there is a price different
differentiation ratio and in 2019
you instructed on
adjusting
the legislation of the russian
federation to leave the restrictions of
the
pride differentiation ratio for the
medical services but five regions
of the far eastern arctic they still
unrefunded for about 14 billion rubles
and we do not think about the birth and
death rates and the lack of this
flexibility does not allow us to get the
funding that we need to
attain the goals that we were said we do
not
think about the increase of the prices
on vaccination and other expenses
that's why we get the funding deficit
and the same audit that we got from the
medical help center control center we
are talking about 50 billion ripples for
the entire far eastern healthcare system
mr putin
there is a golden rule when you
criticize make suggestions with all the
other far eastern regions we
worked on these merits and we are ready
to come up
with certain ideas that would allow us
to keep the compulsory insurance system
at place and to find new solutions what
do we suggest to switch to the dynamic
planning and managing system
which is done now in construction
industry first of all to create digital
basis for the economic management to
introduce criteria to change to the new
funding systems to
organize the
accounting for the actual needs of the
medical facilities that
actual funding that they need to
continue operating and to allocate
additional funding from the federal
budget not to
recalculate this inside
the region so
here mr putin
and uh think that you see the improving
living conditions of the people and far
east the highest priority please create
a task force group to consider our
suggestions
at the state council that is going to
take place in september and also please
instruct to consider to help with the
paying out the debt of our health care
thank you for your attention thank you
very much
so now we'd like to give the floor maybe
to hear out some comments regarding this
yes
mr putin dear colleagues
when we talk about the social and
economic development i would like to
talk about a number of things
so first on the infrastructure
that's true recently we are introducing
new healthcare facilities we're
launching new healthcare facilities in
the last two years we have launched
197 in 19 and 20 and as part of the
upgrade project we are going to launch
300 new sites and we are going to
innovate even more so
that's how we meet the criteria but at
the same time when we talk about the
infrastructure of the far eastern health
care it requires
some
targeted decisions for example in
kamchatka because we are completing the
construction of the
or the oncology patients in megaden
region and we are not talking about the
primary care
but uh we are doing the same work in the
transpical region a number of other
regions
so of course we need to invest into the
development of infrastructure and we
plan to
supply more medical equipment and we
have already started supplying this
equipment and
almost 10 percent of this equipment has
already been delivered as for
rehabilitation we have already allocated
funds for this program and the far
eastern regions are going to
get this funding to develop their
infrastructure and to pay
for the medical help that people need
and what we have just heard
funding
for the clinics that already exist so
first of all we talk about the salaries
in the forest so it is higher than the
russian federation the share of salaries
in all total expenses
so the difference is almost 1.5 times
and the number of regions and first of
all i'm talking about magadan regions so
it is
higher than what we anticipated on
average and the share of expenses on
salaries and the level of salaries has
increased
in comparison to what we anticipated
which is an additional burden to the
budget but because of the climate
because of the geography because of the
remoteness of the settlements
payments of the compulsory insurance
system the infrastructure that we
maintain
that we have to maintain because of the
specificity of the region so it does not
cover it so we want to achieve nothing
with reallocating funds so for the next
year we will change the difference
differentiation ratio
we will put 6.2 billion reboots to be
allocated
and we are going to allocate additional
funds this year to finance the health
care systems we have already allocated
85 billion dribbles but only compulsory
insurance system can't pay for the
infrastructure that we need to maintain
in those regions
so it will it would be too hard as for
the
personnel
on average
it is the situation is better than an
average in russia we
talk about the population but then again
the
special requirements for the uh
infrastructure
the dry more sites so that's why they
need more medical professionals because
we heard about two examples about really
remote settlements
in kamchatka
and in magadan region
we now
uh increased the amount of students by
so we increased the funding for the
regional doctorate program which allow
us to increase the number of
participants by 30 percent and according
to our forecast 600 more medical
professionals will join this industry
which is 20 bigger than we used to have
before
and we see a lot of potential to improve
the demographic
numbers and
number of areas because we should talk
about this region separately we talk
about the medical examinations and we
talk about deeper medical examinations
and the vaccination
and
it really helps with preventing the
diseases including the coronavirus
infection but here is what i would like
to mention especially
we should put more emphasis to
to decrease the
external
causes of death because
some of the numbers are really bad we
are talking about the drinking problems
and unhealthy
lifestyle that's why we support support
the suggestion to have a task force
group working group to resolve a number
of features that we talked about today
and we are preparing the number of
suggestions on our behalf as well
so the task force how
do you suggest to create it it's going
to be the working group within the
government
this working group should include the
representatives from the government and
for from the regions because
if we talk about the far east
there is a lot of diversity there and we
will need to come up the solution for
five regions separately so that's why we
won't be able to make it work without
regional specialists we won't be able to
make really good targeted solutions
so this working group is going to be at
the state council working group right
he has cheered by the governor governor
of ivanova region so i think we can do
this with his support and we have him
here right so please the floor is yours
so can you hear me mr putin yes we can
hear you loud and clear please
well first of all the
matter is about the funding of the
promote healthcare sides that's doesn't
only concern the farce so we are going
to think about it and we were instructed
up for the previous state council as for
the far east issues
then of course we will use the state
council health health care commission to
talk about it we have the representative
from the far east and this commission we
will do it no no we need to
make it a separate
group within your commission we will do
this of course
and
let's call it the subcommittee and you
know for mr inusef is going to chair
this subcommittee
we will do it
sure
thank you
and now i
don't give the floor to the ministry of
finance obviously they have a lot of
problems
are going to have a lot of problems with
this suggestion so they need to think
about it they need to understand the
the matters that we are discussing and
they need to come up with a really
state scope
solutions for this matter not just to
use some patterns but we need to keep in
mind the specific features of the region
now belizev
flor is yours thank you very much mr
putin your colleagues
in my report i will try to answer the
questions that were
raised in
your introductory speech but first i
would like to give you some numbers some
figures that would
uh
paint the picture for you the total
amount of the
avia transportation without the
foreign transportation when it peaked in
2019 reached almost 8 million people 7.9
million people have to be precise per 8
million people so this mobility
coefficient the main factor that we use
was almost
one which is a very high indicator
and it takes a very complex set of
measures to support it especially since
recently because of the covet it
decreased significantly the total amount
of flights
dropped to 5.5 million people i'm
talking about the forest and this year
it's
being restored gradually but i don't
think that we will go higher than seven
million people we plan for about 6.8 so
this mobility coefficient decreased and
the key goal that we have is to bring it
back to the previous peak level to this
one coefficient because now it's 0.8 i
think it's going to be about 0.8
and most of these flights about 90 of
these flights
these are long haul
flights
that all the state support program are
aimed at so that's what i'm going to
talk about i'm going to talk about
interregional
operations so we have four federal
programs to support the
operation the flights between the far
eastern regions and the total amount is
almost 13 billion rubles
12.6 which is a record number for the
recent years so the first program is the
support program for the certain
categories of the passengers retirees
students disabled persons and families
with the
multiple children then all the
passengers on the most vital routes and
the third the support of the certain
routes between the regions and the force
subsidized of the social droughts
under the aurora airline company so
under these four programs the
we
have serviced served 1.5 billion people
which is also record number for the
recent years we're talking about 24.5
percent from the long-haul operations
and apart from these direct
uh subsidizing whales we have a federal
program uh flat tariff
by the air flood company and by a russia
air company and it covers
1.3 million people more
and the expenses for your better and
understanding airflow expenses to
implement this program within seven
months
was 6.7 billion rubles and
throughout the year it's going to be
more than 10 billion rubles the expense
of that irf law is going to help so it's
similar to the total amount of the state
support
and the state support and this flat
tariff of the airport we have covered
2.7
flights which is almost 45 of all the
flights
to long haul operations i'm talking
about the flight between the regions for
the far eastern population and four
billion rebels more are spent by the
regions of the russian federation i'm
talking about the far east here to
support the
travels and trips
within inside the forest
thus
the tools that we have they are quite
large-scale
so does it mean that there is nothing
else to do of course not and you said it
yourself so i would like to talk about
individual programs so the first program
supporting the individual categories at
the past develop program we have it from
the 2019 it covers 91 route 99. 91
flight and uh the budget of this program
is 4 billion rubles
so
463 000 passengers per year and 410 000
passengers have already used this
program and the price of the ticket is
about two three times lower than the
commercial price for example
the flight
from myrna to sochi according to this
program is 7.5 000 rubles and the
commercial price is 17 000 dixie moscow
dixie ramen
12 000 and the commercial price is 42
000 etc etc if we
go back to your introductory speech mr
putin then this program
can be used
to allocate funds automatically because
it's in very high demand
and
as of today or
for 28th of august we have already sold
105 of tickets that we have planned
for example if a retiree or a
family with uh many children would like
to go somewhere in september or october
they wouldn't be able to buy tickets
under this program technically
because all the funds have been used all
the flights that were done under this
program
has been implemented by 85 percent
that's why i fully support
the suggestion to
to implement the automatical approach
within this program
of course it should still be managed by
the transportation ministry finance
ministry and the companies should be
reimbursed
i'm talking about the expenses that they
carry when they service the people that
can use this program and i think we are
going to need one or two more billion
rubles billion rebels more if we look at
the volume of the ticket sales that we
have by now the second program that i
would like to talk about the support of
all the people of the far east that has
been launched as per per decision of the
president in this year
it's very much in demand so it covers
11.
the price of this program is 5 billion
rubles
and
about 500 000
people is its capacity we have already
transported half of it to 150 000
passengers so of course this program
should be
fine-tuned in the future as well and
first we need to make it clear and to
expand the number of the
routes covered by this program as of
today when we
transportation ministry came up with the
list of these routes we thought about
the most popular routes
if we talk about the ticket price and
about the market demand
and uh since we had limited financial
resources five billion rubles we
chose 11 rounds that i mentioned already
and then two regional centers weren't
included yakuza moscow wasn't included
into this list and chita moscow was also
not a part of this program and i can say
right away that that was wrong and that
this route should be a part
of this program should be covered by
this program and uh
another wrong thing is that
only moscow became a part of this
program but not saint petersburg for
example and we agreed with the ministry
of finance
that next year this program will be
expanded to 6.5 billion rubles if you
support it and it will cover 21 route
including
some of the routes to saint petersburg
and obviously all the routes from the
regional centers
of the forest and secondly we need to
decrease the depth of booking because
what we have now as soon as people
learned about the existence of this
program
in the on the very first month
the most of the tickets were booked
until the end of the year so
if we talk about today in total they
bought out more than 70 of the tickets
and we
think it should be done and the way to
limit
the
possibility of doing it like that and to
decrease the depth of booking uh to set
a limit of six months or maybe a little
bit more for the people to plan for
their vacation trips but not to have a
situation when in the middle of the year
on most of these routes
there are no more tickets and people
have
no
possibility to buy subsidized tickets
anymore and the third suggestions that
we have
under this program is to limit the
number of trips for one individual since
we issue
tickets to a certain individual we can
do this because we can see that the
number of resources under this program
are used to subsidize business trips
but this program is aimed at social
routes and social
trips and travels
so for example for a person to see their
relatives to go on holiday but when
someone flies five or six times to
moscow and back and obviously they have
some business goals in mind then we need
to
draw a line here so
they should buy the should pay the
commercial price and the third program's
subsidizing
certain inter-regional routes these are
federal program and it covers all the
regions of the russian federation and
the budget of this program for is almost
8 billion rubles
it's going to be expanded to
some 10 billion rebels
and the far eastern regions get uh two
billions from this amount because the
requirements are stipulated in the rules
the 50 60 of the funding and the far
eastern regions they can't afford to pay
the other 50
so we talked uh about it with uh our
colleagues so we would like to set a
buddha for the far east and we would
like to set it
at 30 that will allow far eastern
regions to use 1 billion rebels more
because now we have 35 rounds there and
we think that this program is quite
in demand and secondly we need to look
closely at the routes and to make them
clear because this program has existed
since 2013 so maybe some other routes
they don't need any subsidies
and the fourth program
is subsidizing social routes under
within the
aurora air company
operations i would like to remind you so
aurora airline has existed
and then gradually
five
largest carriers
were added and now uh
aurora has 25
plus one share
in these airline companies so all the
regions of the pharisees participate in
this program 10 regions
are
they on five percent of the companies so
and suckling have
55 55
minus one share
and the plane fleet is 131
planes and as you've mentioned in your
introduction an agreement has already
been signed to buy 45 more planes before
the end of 2025
as part of the consolidated aggregated
order
and we talked about this at the max of
asian salon
and all the decisions were made there as
well and i would like to say that
launching this company
would serve as an impetus
to implement
the support
of inter-regional short-haul flights in
the forest inside the forest but it
would also work for
flying outside the region it will allow
us to consolidate the measures of the
state support and it will allow us to
optimize
the
to use the planes that we have in more
efficient way
because the
there is an exchange of the
we're switching the larger planes
forward planes so and we agree that we
are going to decrease
this uh
two large planes by
using
russian
uh vehicles more and thank uh superchat
and ms21
l114
and and so on and so forth
so i'm talking about those planes who
work better at such flights and that's
how we are going to save more money
if we talk about the figures then you
talked about 530 flights it's we're
talking about 2022
here and most of these flights is 474
flights are subsidized social routes
and more than one million people are
going to be cured
on the release program
and there is a financial model to have
route and 530 social routes and almost
two million people will use this program
and
there are three things that i would like
to mention critical things first
all the the company
if we talk about its uh financial model
is going to generate losses so this
company
and i would like to address the governor
that
will hear me
it wouldn't work in the same way as i
are thought of the russia airline air
company so it is very important for the
regions of the russian federation to
keep the funding to keep supporting the
social routes that
you are doing today
which is about 4 billion dribbles i
would like to ask you not to decrease
the funding thinking that the budget or
the company itself will be able to carry
this burden to pay for it because the
company will expand its operations
they are going to try to work more
efficiently but they are going to use
these funds to start to launch new
routes and to serve more passengers
second thing we need operational
subsidies we have agreed for the year of
2022 about the volume of operational
subsidies to cover the expenses of about
6 billion dribbles so we have already
done all the calculations uh finance
ministry have already approved them
endorsed them
and we suggest for the years 2023 and
2024 keeping in mind the plan of the
company to launch new routes and to
increase the number of the passengers
they serve on these social flights to
increase the subsidies operational
subsidies for 2023 it is going to be 7
billion
and then we haven't finished the
calculations for the
2024 and but still we have the number of
routes we have the number of passengers
we have agreed
uh the number of this flight and
passengers with the region so i it was
approved by the board so hopefully
we are going to get support and regard
of these figures and we will be able to
come up with a budget for 2023 and 2024.
and thirdly
uh the acquisition of the planes the
parameters the requirements of this
acquisitions have been stipulated
so we
have come up with the requirements for
the planes and
the price expectations and i would like
to thank the mr butcher of the industry
trade who participated actively in this
work secondly
we
have made a decision
that the company is not going to own
these plans it's going to lease these
planes it's going to use the same
mechanism that we use for the
consolidated state order that we've
discussed that you're meeting at the max
air salon and
it will allow us to make this
mechanism
more efficient for the budget and
thirdly the funds that we are going to
allocate to subsidize the leasing ratio
losing rate
to subsidize the requirement of
these planes these capital subsidies
they will be a part of the general
subsidies
including
the
under the consolidated state order
and the figures that we have for the
funding is about 2.8 billion 2022 and
4.2 billion and 2020 three and seven
billion and 2024
that's what i wanted to to to tell about
the direct subsiding
mechanism
and uh we have already created all
necessary mechanisms all necessary tools
but we need to fine-tune it further and
i've already talked about this and there
are also some measures and i wouldn't
talk about it in too much detail because
the president has heard about it to
decree the expenses for the carriers
because their expenses they define the
ticket price in the end we are talking
first of all about the
efficiency regarding the capacities of
how much how many passengers plane can
carry so we will do it with updating the
plane fleet and the second urgent
problem is the decrease of the
fuel price and we have anti mana police
department working on it and if large
ports like and vladivostok and habars so
they managed to resolve this problem one
way or another in smaller airports
the fuel price
is higher
by
14 60 sometimes twice as much
and
thirdly we can decrease
decrease the expenses by decreasing the
fees
imposed on smaller airports
and
some fees that some of the airports is
uh
are twice as big
and we are going to change this
situation too
so to reach the
goals that we have
and to reach this one coefficient ratio
and even to go higher my report is over
thank you for your attention
mr limarenko the floor is yours now
a lot has been said regarding the
aviation matters i would like to add a
couple of things
so we have created the unified for
eastern air company and we have
allocated funds to subsidize
1 billion 850 million have been
allocated i would like to say that the
range of prices from 2200 rubles to 10
950 rebels
that's a good indicator and the
populations are
is happy with these prices
and they
have already seen that this price
prices are real and i would like to give
you some example of what changes
happened
when we introduced these 20 new routes
before passengers from urs nasalins can
come to moscow they reached these cities
it took 24 hours to get there with
transfers
and they spent much more money and now
they have direct flights so it takes
only 1.5 hours and the price of the
ticket is about 4 600 robots from
shuttling to petropalvas kamchatki
doesn't take
eight hours it takes only three hours
and the ticket price has also decreased
three times these are some of the
examples where we can show people what
changes happened and i would like to be
honest with you
it was uh
expensive because in august everyone
comes back from their holidays and this
that's the time
when
they started feeling this support
and as that's been mentioned by 2025 we
plan to increase
to introduce
more than 113 new routes and aurora
within its operation is going to serve
no less than 2.5 million passengers and
i would like to say right away that us
governors
we discussed all these routes we talked
about all these routes and that's what
people really need and we are going to
come up with additional suggestions
later and i would like to support the
suggestions on subsidizing of the of the
price so it all corresponds to the
reality so i'm not going to comment this
i would just join the suggestions that
have been voiced
now
the next thing as for the airplanes
that's right 45 airplanes the price is
57 billion
and we're losing about 93 billion of
course we won't be able to return these
investments with the
tickets that we sell so we need the
support from the finance ministry and i
would like to say right away the
suggestions that we heard
from mr pelosi we are completely
satisfied with that now is for the fuel
issue
if we
talk about the price from the
competitiveness
level
then
we won't be able to compete with the
other countries with the jet fuel prices
that we have and we plan that the huge
succulents is going to be a large
aviation hub so we are being
a building
new takeaway
strip and uh we're going to build a new
airport and we need to remain
competitive so we need to resolve this
problem with the jet fuel price and i
would like to talk about one of the
scenarios that could be efficient we are
talking with gaspron now to
produce uh jet fuel from the gas
candidate
this decision has been made yet we are
only talking
about uh some pilot project this year so
we are going to make all efforts
to
make gas prem to produce this fuel by
competitive prices then the jet fuel is
going to be cheap on sakhalin and then
we will be able to implement this
project and apart from the jet fuel we
can also produce gasoline and the diesel
fuel because these are very much needed
car fuel
and the population will support this
initiative
for sure because
there is certain social tensions when
the prices grow and every person
living in the forest they think that
the region where they extract oil
should have cheap prices for the oil
products and this decision about
producing fuel on sakhalin is going to
resolve all these problems we are in
talks right now so we would like to get
support in this respect as well
and now some
couple of words about maritime transport
naval transport sahlin is the only
state in the russian federation
that the only region
on the island so the transport issue is
a very important issue for us
so we introduced two new ships that were
manufactured in saint petersburg
and in the future
we are expecting two more
chips
that is going to increase the
transportation coefficient between the
sakhalin and the mainland
and we are going to implement the
bridge building project which will help
us
to
create better accessibility of cycling
and the development of the naval
transport is
held out by the krosakov port
development
and the russian ship
fishing business we would like to move
it from busan in korea to sakhalin we
are going to create new jobs we're going
to get more money for the budget and we
are going to upgrade the
production facilities as well and
at the eastern economic forum we have
signed a deal with investors that are
ready to invest a lot
to
such facility for storage and
processing office so it's going to be
the largest facility in the world and
we're also going to
renovate the
facilities at corsac port to expand its
infrastructure
and
it will be funded
from the state budget starting from 2026
and we would like to expedite this
decision and to start designing these
facilities next year starting from 2022
so that
investors
that
process fish they could plan at the same
time their capacities and their
capabilities and that they could build
their own plans then in the next four
years we will be able to upgrade the
port and to build new production
facilities allocation of new funding
will allow us to
support the current terminal the
kursakov port is the key to the
development of sakhalin and kuril island
so we ask request your support thank you
for your attention
15 billion for how many years you said
for three years
so it's 5 billion
some 5 billion per year we need about 1
billion for
designing and then 4 or 5 billion
to get the work done
2022 is for designing we have already
came up with technical specifications we
presented to the transport ministry and
they support us with this project
so let's keep this in mind we are going
to
work with the agencies but i really like
the idea itself thank you very much
so now the floor is to our next speaker
yes i'm here i'm so pleased the floor is
yours
yes that's that's what i want from you
to comment on what has been said your
colleagues allow me to start with the
subsidies
uh what has been said that's completely
true the only thing
that i would like you to instruct the
transport
ministry and finance ministry not only
to come up with algorithm
because it's a really nice idea to come
up with an algorithm to allocate
subsidies because
that's the picture that we have and i
already reported to you for example 2018
decree number 215 that's the decree
executive order for the special segments
of the people in the forest
4.2 billion
and another decree flight it's not from
moscow it's three or four so
7.6 billion we got in 2018 2019 we
transported the most passengers
128 million people the year before the
covet pandemic and the location of
subsidies
to the entire program
is 15 billion
2020 is 15.2 billion now we have a
record here we have already allocated
21.4 billion rubles and
and the transport ministry you want to
have 5.4
billion more and if this money are not
allocated within a week then companies
are will not be able to use this 5.4
billion because high season is almost
over because the school year has started
so if we allocate this money within the
week then most of it will be allocated
to the forest
according to the executive order 215
and regarding all the segments of the
population so i would like to have an
algorithm for everything so that we
allowed people to be more mobile because
we need to increase this mobility to the
factor of one because it's twice as bad
is
in europe and four times as bad as in
the us but we need money to make it work
so
and we should also increase the amount
of passenger this year we are going to
reach uh the 100 million people and 88
million
inside russia itself what we have the
kobe is introducing a lot of
restrictions for the flights and what we
have as a result all the air companies
they
are now working more for russia and
we carry
17 percent of passengers more than in
the past pre-coveted here so
if
you support me mr putin we should come
up with an algorithm for all the
subsidies not only for the forest and
there is a clear algorithm i don't think
it will be a big problem to come up with
an algorithm so we will try to develop
it and to can
give it to the government's
consideration as for the kresac report
yes we support this idea in this project
and
as law stipulates
we have a investment declaration
so we need to talk about the cargo
volume we need to think about the
facilities that we will need to build
there so we support the project in
general but we need to study deeper to
make a final decision that's what we are
going to make as per the instruction
that we are going to get later today is
for the
other projects
then after we will be the trans-siberian
and michael amor
roads
that we are going to use to increase the
throughput capacity we are working on
this project as well we have entry
points and rational railroads are
working on this project so i read their
project so their draft but it's going to
take a lot of money to build because on
the succulent now we have already
replaced the railroads to the russian
standard 1520 and a lot of other matters
are being resolved but to make a final
decision we will need to make
certain assessments and estimations
because to
build a breach it's going to be an
expensive
undertaking
the bridge itself so we support this
project but we need to talk about it
separately that's all i
wanted to say thank you my report is
over
we are not talking about the
entry points for the bridge but we will
need to develop everything
around this bridge to build new roads so
it's not only the entry point for the
breach
that's right
you're right
okay fine thank you
if anyone else has anything to say then
please
take the floor but other than that i
don't want to
to force you to talk if you don't have
anything to say
i wanted to press the button to ask for
the floor because there is so many
financial matters
and so many
topics that need to be discussed first
of all the
budget funding
they were talking about the lack of
budget funding for the far eastern
regions
so here's what i would like to say in
this respect
we have
made calculations the budget funding
so we are spending money to
make it equal but if we will consider
all the money transfer subsidies other
budgetary grants
six regions out of 11 if we talk about
the forest
they have the budget fundings with
subsidies and other targeted grants so
they get more money than on average and
as per your instruction regarding
7.2 percent of all the investments
then being made from the federal budget
they should be allocated to the far east
because remember this instruction made
several years ago at this firm so you
instructed and you kept it under your
control so i report now that today's
figures are 17.4 percent
so you asked for 7.2 and we have 17.4 so
when we say that lance
give more money to support the region
i think we should talk about the fishing
rod so we should develop the economy we
should invest more into the enterprises
and then
investments are growing economy is
developing
but then it's weird to hear from the
from our counterpart that we are lacking
this we're electing that so now let's
take a look at the current situation we
can see that in the far eastern regions
we have a good situation with the income
and we plan good income next year
because we have double digits growth of
the income in comparison with the last
year sometimes we can see 20 30 percent
growth
in certain regions of the russian
federation
and
that's why i think our job is to create
conditions for further development and
we have special tax regime and it works
and a lot has been said about it
and there is a special program
that is being expanded if we're talking
about uh the funding i will talk about
it later
and
it is program aimed at creating new jobs
and uh at improving the living
conditions for the people
and of course we have others
support instruments to do this
so
i think
making all the regions equal or
equalizations of all the regions it
could be
bad for the development why should we
work hard if everyone will be equal but
attracting new investment private
investment using the support of the
federal budget for these particular
goals i think that's the right way to go
and now the second suggestions regarding
suggestion of sakhalin regarding the
demographic situation we have just
adopted the demographic package of
measures and we have started
implementing them this year and we are
talking about the support of families
with the children who had their first
child second child third child
and we have made the decision to support
the families with the children who have
children of various ages single parent
families
and we have just started implementing
these projects these programs so i think
this matter of the possibility of
supporting individual regions of the
russian federation and uh
expanding this practice to everyone we
still need to estimate the result of
this program because we will see the
first results of that large package of
measures that we have
adopted
this year and these results they will
sure
how it works so let's wait for these
results first now the renovation of the
cities we support it fully
what do we need
we have adopted a number of measures
that have been implemented fully yet
so we are implementing the decisions
that we have uh adopted previously so
what are these decisions we give
investment loans 500 billions throughout
the country as for the far eastern
regions
30 plus billion dribbles we have
allocated have you used all of them not
yet
the regions have just started coming up
with their applications for this so
let's allocate this resource to develop
city infrastructure city transport
and that would be the right thing to do
to restructure the loans and to
reallocate these new loans for new
infrastructure projects because the far
eastern regions
they didn't really react to these
suggestions but why let's use this
instrument as well
and the next instrument the far eastern
program
we are expanding the far eastern
programs and we have made calculations
about the additional income that we are
going to get
it will increase by 52 billion rubles 52
billion rebels
the total program is
152 additional
billion additionally so it's a good
uh resource to use to renovate cities
and to achieve the goals of development
so
that's the source that we can use now
next
compulsory
insurance megadon doesn't have enough
money from the compulsory insurance
program and we have talked about this a
lot
so let's change the formula of the
compulsory insurance mechanism we have
the bar now
of the price difference differentiation
coefficient 4.5 percent so let's
increase it gradually
when the
health insurance is growing so that we
didn't decrease it in the other region
so let's do this we agreed to
do it 5.5 and then gradually we can
reach six and further
so we agreed to reach six percent by
2024 so let's do this and i
think
that all these conversations that we
like this or like that we have enough of
everything enough of instruments enough
of resources but we need to use it
and we need to be more positive in our
discussions because a lot has been done
and we already
see this the next matter about the
flights that they don't have enough
funding there is enough funding every
year we are increasing the funding and i
agree with that as for the social
subsidies
we need as mr joseph said that should be
made automatic so if they use more than
let's subsidize more
so let's look at the
income about the certain segments of a
population 69 percent
tickets have been bought the subsidies
that we introduced five billion rubles
for the people of the forest 42
of the
funding has been used 42
i repeated and it's september the first
already as for the original subsidy is
50 percent
so jury colleagues and what they said
the 20 of the tickets weren't booked yet
so
we don't have any disaster on our hands
no it's the other way around we can
develop it further and before the forum
we sat down with our colleagues shared
by mr billy youssef and we agreed to
develop this program further but we need
to adjust the mechanism a little bit so
not to have this overlap of subsidies
under different programs upward under
different state subsidies so that people
who wanted to buy tickets they could buy
tickets because some people now they
they buy tickets 12 months in advance
and then they return it so the money are
not used and people who would want to
use this ticket they missed this
opportunity because the ticket was
booked so we need to make these
mechanisms more efficient so it's not
about funding it's about the decisions
that will allow us to use the tools that
we have more efficiently that's why a
lot is done on the forest
enough money is allocated for the forest
and we will continue to allocate money
but you need these resources and not
only the resources of the federal center
now everyone is saying so yes use
federal budget
you should use all kind of money
regional money municipal money
uh
money from funds from the compulsory
insurance program as well so the way we
see it you should have more positive
attitude
about the goals and about the solutions
about the programs that are being
implemented thank you very much yes a
lot is done i agree with that
but not enough yet if we look at the
people moving out from the region
if we decrease the
the rate of people living but if it was
as good as we would like to see it if
people felt good here then they would
move in here they wouldn't moved out
from here an hour ago
large-scale goal not only to keep people
in the regions that were
discovered by our ancestors we should
multiply the demographic so yes we
should increase production capabilities
create jobs
uh help people to earn money that's
these are obvious things self-evident
things and we should use things that we
have
and we should
uh allocate enough funds so you should
use these funds efficiently that's right
as for the compulsory insurance program
and
we know that the situation
about the
smaller settlements smaller villages so
we need to readjust the formula we
should think about how to make it
correspond to the reality
to what we actually have on the ground
because our ideas of
how good would it be if these resources
were enough but it's obviously not
enough if we talk about smaller towns
and smaller villages so we should think
about it we should look into this issue
and we should readjust the formulas
as for the
renovation of the cities so
that's true we have allocated
uh 500 billion drupals that's a lot of
money so this money should work and in
the forest as well and the government
should take a look and come up with
priorities
how to use this money more efficiently
and i'm not talking about this 500
billion we have other infrastructure
projects and 100 billion reboots more
because that that's true we allocate a
lot of money
and the amount of money will the kid we
have never done this before so we have
money and you need to use them smartly
and on time and as for the support for
the families with children yes that's
true we have
introduced a lot of new support measures
but we are all aware and i'm talking
about the government marriage members
now that's not enough
that's
our assumption we don't have the full
package of measures starting from the
birth of a child and finishing with them
graduating from school so that's what we
should have and ask instructed
government to work on it but these are
just general things and we need to think
about targeted measures of support of
families with children
in the forest specifically why
the same
how we create more of
beneficial conditions in the economy to
get more investment we should create
more beneficial conditions for the
families to make it more attractive to
have families to start families here to
have children here not like all across
the country but it should be even more
attractive
in the forest so you should think about
it too so don't forget about it all
these suggestions don't just
forget about them but look into them
deeper
we didn't plan uh planet for today's
meeting but i would like to
uh ask uh
mr partnership to give floor to mr
potter chef
to
hear about
what we have in informing in the forest
the situation
in agriculture in the foreign
i saw an increase in the median salaries
on agricultural
salary in the agricultural sector
mr president
right now
the harvesting season is in effect and
we see an increase in the yield
a similar positive trend can be seen in
the production of vegetables over 11 000
tons
have been
harvested
this
region is not
always
provided
supplied with vegetables but the harvest
continues and
after 2021 we believe that about a
million
tons of grain will be harvested and the
forest is one of the
key product producers of
soybeans as well
we expect to reach the level of last
year despite the difficult weather
condition
mr president a few words again about the
emergency situation
in a few regions of the far
east the damages is estimated at 830
million rubles now we have evaluated all
the regions excluding the jewish
autonomous region we haven't seen the
documentation yet
the damage is 776
million rubles the compensation can be
carried out
thanks to special
agreements and contracts unfortunately
in some of the areas these contracts
have not been signed but the money can
still be compensated uh
from the budget
and
we saw an increase
in
poultry and
and
we expect an increase
in
in cattle breeding in the end of this
year and the early next year the
production of meat and sub products of
meat has increased by 60 percent flowers
by 37 percent
larger by 30 percent we expect
the
good industry
to reach the levels of last year
by the end of this year
as for us
state
support
this year
we are planning to allocate 9 billion
rubles this is uh one and a half billion
more than last year
and we can increase production boost
production you have seen new projects
presented to you today that will be
launched
in the far east of russia
the
in this index of uh
production
is now one hundred and two point four
percent
also
we have agreed with mendel vostok that
starting from 2022 we will implement the
mechanism of
uh reimbursing capital investment into
production of vegetables in
greenhouses
and we expect that this will
help provide
the vegetable supply
in these regions
also subsidizing transportation tariffs
for the regions is also
part of the program
preferences for our farmers
here around tariffs
for
vegetables
various
fertilizers
etc also
fish soybeans and fish protests which is
produced in access in the region will be
exported
also in the far east we have a
coefficient
special coefficient in terms of
budgetary financing
i think this is where i will stop this
is the outline of the development of our
agriculture in the far east
yes
thank you
so
which are the regions of the far east
that suffered the most from uh the
natural disasters of this year
yes give me a minute let me see
autonomous region
do you
see any support from the ministry coming
your way
your region
yes i think mr president yes we have
been receiving support from the ministry
we have
submitted
our documentation to the ministry and we
have received support
sometimes
even after the water recedes after the
flood sometimes we can collect some of
the harvest unfortunately this year this
uh turned out to be impossible
now we still have commissions uh that
will be evaluating the damage
unfortunately most of the houses have
been destroyed
another issue another question
the
insurance of agricultural producers
the insurance systems
unfortunately the system is not really
operational
insuring insurance companies
to do everything
actually doing everything to not pay up
after an accident or a natural disaster
occurs
and so i think that this uh help this
help with insurance should also be
extended to individual farmers
i think this is a matter to be discussed
we are ready to analyze the reasons and
join the discussion thank you
yes thank you
please
consider that in some of the regions
such as the amur region
our colleagues are not yet prepared to
provide the documents
the papers required to
carry out
the
measures that we've discussed
please take this into account and truly
and
address this issue properly as for my
colleagues in the regions i would
ask you to
be
very quick to react to
all that happens and provide
all the necessary documents and submit
all the necessary documents to receive
aid
as for the insurance issue
now we have been talking about that for
several years now so if you have any
specific proposals please just give give
them to us and we will start the work
speaking about the
could you
go through the
basic industries
uh ship buildings
space industry etc
yes thank you first i would like to
provide the figures for the past seven
months
in the processing industry in the
manufacturing industry the growth has
been over 100 percent and the premorse
region it's 115
overall the
there has been an increase
in production volumes uh barring few
regions
just yesterday i have been to kamchatka
an enterprise which is
launching launching the production of
six
new uh ship
fishing vessels
the enterprise has been
basically are just destroyed of bankrupt
before the
the new measures have been
taken to address
this
issue and
right now i can say that there has been
lots of progress these shapes are being
built
the commission is
up to 2024
and our colleagues will invest into the
further development of this enterprises
including efforts to repair uh other
ships and vessels so there's one
proposal i would like to make
and just yesterday
like i said
i think we should remove the value and
attacks
for maintenance of civil vessels
civilian vessels including shipping
vessels because right now
the most of the repairs that
is made is in korea in in japan
so fish
fishing
companies are sending their ships
to other countries
but this could be done in russia in the
far east
and in kamchatka
one example is that this company is
ready to develop these
capabilities but we need to have to be
motivated to
uh to be competitive with the
foreign companies
i think this is reasonable
but i think that this will not
negatively affect the
taxes that are coming to the budget
because right now all this money is
coming abroad is going abroad
so if the ministry of finance is uh will
support this uh initiative
i think we can go forward with that
now as for other projects
such as the metallurgy
and
other industries developing in the far
east
we're talking about resources that are
being
developed and produced in the country
but small and medium-sized projects are
also being developed just yesterday
in kamchatka we have visited an
enterprise that produces
uh
bigger tree tree capsules
and this is
not just fish oil
this is
actually
something different they take white wild
salmon and
uh take uh the head part of the fish
and extract this oil this is a green
ecologically clean product
and
i think that
all of the colleagues here in the paris
will support
this initiative
to
help develop this industry because
omega-3 fats are very uh good for health
of both adults and children
now
we are quite loaded right now with uh
when it comes to
shipbuilding enterprises
we understand as for the aviation
i think that
we have uh agreed on all the parameters
with the parameters with the ministry of
finance for the year up to
up to the year 2035
i think that uh
all the orders will be completed
in time
on time
as for ship building and aviation
in the regions
industrial infrastructure will be
established
in the form of industrial parks
because entrepreneurs
find it much easier to come to an
already prepared infrastructure not into
a open field where there's nothing
um
because number of regions have already
launched industrial parks
and have been receiving
state support
and they and we expect that this
initiative will be supported by the
ministry of finance to help the far
eastern regions
so that they can make use of the
measures of the support measures and
governmental aid that is provided we
have
investment
to develop infrastructure and if this
this help comes it will be compensated
through the taxes federal taxes paid
by the residents of these regions and
not long ago decision has been made that
these investors just yesterday
we have been to kamchatka and looked at
that
this individual interpreters private
entrepreneurs
can receive
up to 50 compensation
if he invests uh
in
the industrial park
and i think that this will be a great uh
boon to help
start
these
projects
we also expect the regions
to actively
submit applications so for
uh
loans and
at lower rates
and just recently we have been to
yakutia
and talked about
establishing
these projects
there as well and i hope that
the far eastern regions will follow suit
thank you
yes thank you
as for the vastness spaceport we will
discuss that later
now anton gomez
how about we discuss the uh value added
tax in shipbuilding as well
you don't need to answer me right now
just look into it and report to me later
because i would really want the volume
of
orders that and commissioning that
goes to foreign companies actually be
rerouted to russian enterprises we need
to support our shipbuilding
industry
now
i'd like to give the floor to mr falcov
about the academy of sciences and high
schools and the situation with education
here
mr president uh thank you so much
this is the year of science and
technology and we have been paying
special attention to
science and higher education first of
all i would like to inform you
that education in the far east
uh is going
in accordance
with
your order we have been increasing the
number of
um
education
states and
[Music]
opportunities for young people to
receive education for free are paid in
both by the budget
or next year we're going to have over 30
660 of them
now the younger generation is also very
interested in network programs
and they would like to
while studying here they would like to
also
receive education from the leading
russian universities and we have last
year we have uh launched a
very interesting program
headed by the saint petersburg
international
technical building university and with
the help of our universities we have
started
a number of programs
and we have accepted and we have
accepted a number of students
from from the far east
these people will receive education in
the
uh best technical university shelby
university in saint petersburg and they
will be able to
to complete
their
practical training here in the far east
and rosneft will help them find jobs
also here
here in the far east university they
will complete their training
and the pacific fleet will also provide
other opportunities to receive the
military education as well
as for
the higher education
in order to make it
more accessible
and
of higher quality i have reported to you
in spring
that
we have launched a 10-year program 20
for your title priority 2013 and
we will be
selecting students soon we have received
a lot of applications from leading far
eastern universities
by november this year we will inform on
you on how the selection process
was completed
and
students were selected
up to
one billion drupals will be
provided to each university
participating in the program we have
also another initiative
and uh we have been working with each
region and we have developed a special
program to support uh far eastern
universities
we have discussed it with the professors
and administrators of universities
and we have agreed for the next year to
relaunch this program individually in
other regions as for science
the most important event
in the region that we have been
implementing on your order
that will help universities and
institutes in the in the far east
is that
we have selected 15
educational centers and institutes
including the inter-regional educational
center it's called north territory of
sustainable development
and the
actor here
will be university of yakutia
and
the scientific center then
magadan kimchatka and
the succulent region are also
participating
as for kamchatka considering the events
of last year we have developed a special
program
this is a scientific
that will be implemented this year
now also as part of the national project
uh
science at universities
for the first time in the past decade
in 2020 on your order we have
developed
designed uh two new uh scientific
vessels and they have been commissioned
here in rosneft in the
of
region and tomorrow uh
the official ceremony will take place
and i'm
sure that
by 2024 our scientific fleet will
receive two uh new uh state-of-the-art
uh vessels
scientific vessels
that will make us stronger in the world
oceans now
finally in the saint petersburg
international economic forum in spring
you
focused on
the environment and the climate
challenges that we're facing and i
reported to you there in the spring
that by the end of this year we'll be
completing our pilot projects to develop
seven first seven carbon
um
polygons
and one of them
this is an experimental territory
and one of those
territories one of those polygons will
be established here with the help of our
colleagues i think this
mostly covers the efforts that we have
been making thank you mr president
thank you and as for the institutes of
the academy of sciences that
make researches in the maritime biology
and so on and for them specific
specifically we have created additional
opportunities so do they use it do they
develop in this direction
we work with the russian academy of
sciences with our colleagues from the
presidium we help them fully and
while i'm here now and i'm going to
meet my colleagues and talk with them
but we try to join the efforts of our
universities and research organizations
so
we will look into it of course mr putin
okay then thank you
and now
we i hear regular reports on how four
cultural centers are being built in four
cities
congrats to a stoppable camera though in
here
in the forest
but we should
already start to prepare to launch them
which is also a massive effort
and we should
organize all the administrative matters
we should hire
personnel and train the personnel and so
on and so forth so do you think about it
in respect with vladivostok for example
hello mr putin that's true
if we talk about the main issues that we
face is the low level
of the qualified personnel that we can
hire for our cultural facilities and to
resolve this issue we are launching the
branches of the universities we already
have the branch of the central musical
school and choreography school we have
started an art school at the branch of
the russian scenic arts institute and
after the new buildings will be
commissioned and put into operation we
will be able to expand the number of
students of these facilities and
also we have created center of the
retraining where a lot of people could
get additional education if we talk
about the culture
experts and culture professionals and
almost 2 000 people were retraining and
by the end we are going to have 2
657 people who went through this
reiteration program and of course it's
very important for us to have young
people working at this large cultural
centers
we have a very extensive program that we
implement with the tradicov gallery for
our
young museum professionals and we hire a
lot of young and
creative people who travel to the
regions a lot they work with people who
just make their first steps
future experts future museum
professionals and they work together
in vladivostok as well already as for
our main goals
uh
among others
it's our national project culture and
under this national program from 19 to
from 2019 to 2024
regents and the forest will be
allocated 5.9 billion rubles which is
about 10.5 percent from the
total subsidies that the
regions are going to get from the
federal budget
and we have reached all our goals
and uh all our
sides have seen uh have
sold 96 percent of tickets
and we work with all the region
closely in the last year showed that it
is possible if we build an efficient
system of working with the region and if
we can control it along
the entire line from the federal center
to the region to the municipality to a
village
to a individual cultural center and we
considered the suggestions that we got
from the far east so for us it was a
priority
and in 2024 we are going to allocate
more than 11 billion rebels for the
cultural expenses
and our priorities are
villages with the small populations
less than 500 people so we are going to
have their mobile cultural centers
cultural fans
and
villages of 500 500 plus
people they are going to have cultural
centers
and uh larger settlements are going to
have
theaters and movie theaters and
settlements of with population of more
than 10 000 people they are going to
have libraries and museums and for
larger settlements they also are going
to have
leisure parks and so on and so forth so
that's what we are working on and
another thing that we rejoice with is
the
children's school of arts we used to
have we are going to equip 21 school in
2020 one and 40 more in 2022
so we are going to
increase the amount of people going to
this school and we can see that there is
uh
much more interest towards these from
our colleagues in the regions okay thank
you i think we are about to end with our
meeting and here is what i would like to
say
to conclude our today's meeting
i have already mentioned it and i would
like to repeat it so
russia has explored these territories
since a long time ago and we were doing
this
our
famous ancestors did this all previous
centuries millions of our ancestors came
here to explore this land and we
do it with a goal in mind because these
territories the far east
has a huge significance for russia
because it has a huge potential which is
uh obvious i'm not even talking about
the northern sea road about arctic
territories
but even the regions where we
are now or
leaders of which we have here at this
meeting
and
we shouldn't just preserve what our
ancestors did we should
achieve even more
many times more
since these
lands have a lot of potential
have a lot of prospect
just look at how the economy is growing
how asian countries are developing now
and
russia
has this happy opportunity to develop
this territory to become a part of this
quickly-growing
world
so because of all of that we have
launched all the development programs
that have just started to work
but we already can see the results
i agree that we already have some
positive outcome
but to keep up the tempo we need to
work hard work smart
and
we should try to achieve
the ghost that we have set
and i would like to thank all of you for
today's extensive meeting and the
discussion of all the questions that
were raised and i would like to invite
you to
discuss the
further instructions so that we could
get the vital points of the further
development that we talked about today
thank you very much
do
so
you